LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgenen mutuel santé prévoyance
présente état de
[Musique]
santé
la ménopause est encore aujourd'hui
tabou un tiers des Français trouve ce
sujet difficile à aborder c'est des
domaines un peu de l'intime donc c'est
pas c'est pas ça une difficulté
supplémentaire pour certaines femmes qui
vivent des symptômes handicapants au
quotidien ça a été un bouleversement
parce que j'ai j'avais vraiment
l'impression que c'est le corps qui
dirigeait j'avais plus prise et avais
l'impression de de c'est comme si je me
recrquevillais complètement mieux
informer les patientes est essentiel car
il existe des solutions et des
traitements il y a plein de femmes qui
pourraient avoir un traitement hormonal
de la ménopause effectivement si elle le
désire si nous médecins on a estimé que
il n'y avait pas de risque à ce qu'elle
le prenne alors comment mieux aborder ce
sujet de la ménopause pourquoi faut-il
en parler ménopause la fin d'un tabou
c'est le thème de ce numéro de
[Musique]
santé bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
état de santé est-ce que nous parlons
est-ce que vous parlez de la ménopause
dans un repas de famille bah non et si
vous étiez tenté de le faire sans doute
que ça créerait un petit malaise mais
oui c'est un sujet tabou on va en parler
avec vous Laurence Rossignol merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénatrice vous êtes militante de longue
date vous avez été ministre chargé des
droits des femmes avant de voir votre
portrait c'est juste une question qui
concerne toutes les femmes il faut le
rappeler oui et je suis mopposé puis
surtout quand on est féministe qu'on
s'intéresse depuis des années à pousser
toutes les portes des nonit de
l'invisibilisation des femmes de leurs
conditions de vie à un moment donné le
sujet de la ménopause apparaît comme
étant probablement un des derniers gros
tabou ça n'est peut-être pas le dernier
mais en tout cas c'est bien de s'y
attaquer on va en parler ensemble mais
d'abord votre portrait
[Musique]
Laurence Rossignol est sénatrice
socialiste du valde Marne en 2014 elle
est nommée au gouvernement Vals
secrétaire d'État chargé de la famille
et des personnes âgées puis ministre des
familles de l'enfance et des droits des
femmes militante féministe très jeune
elle préside actuellement l'association
l'assemblée des femmes parmi ces combats
briser le tabou de la ménopause en tant
que vice-présidente de la la délégation
au droits des femmes du Sénat elle a en
effet cossigné un rapport qui alerte sur
les impacts spécifiques du travail sur
la santé des femmes en particulier sur
la nécessité d'une meilleure prise en
compte des symptômes de la ménopause
dans le cadre
[Musique]
professionnel lance rignol un un tabou
peut-être pas le dernier mais quand même
un sacré tabou la ménopause c'est
quasiment une honte pourtant c'est pas
une maladie c'est comme la grossesse
c'est pas une maladie mais euh les
femmes n'en parlent pas pourquoi euh la
ménopause c'est comme les règles c'est
comme l'accouchement aussi un peu en
amont de nous-même euh c'est tout ce qui
concerne la santé sexuelle et
reproductive ce sont des sujets dont on
ne parle pas euh avec d'autres on en
parle pas avec les hommes euh la il y a
pas de discussion public sur on parle
même pas à son mari la plupart du temp
on en parle pas à son mari le mari est
un homme le plus souvent on en parle
avec le mari et ce sont des sujets du
monde des femmes et forth heureusement
dans l'histoire des des femmes et des
silences dans lesquel elles évoluent il
y a leur propres parolle ce monde des
femmes dans lesqueles les femmes
transmettent entre elles raconte et elle
elle parle de la ménopause et souvent
elle baisse la voix néanmoins même entre
elle pour parler de la ménopause et donc
c'est un tabou pour toutes les femmes et
ça l'IT de moins en moins peut-être
parce qu'on parle plus des règles
aujourd'hui et donc on pousse une porte
et cette porte elle arrive sur la
ménopause alors la la ménopause c'est un
cycle dans la vie des femmes euh où les
hormones ont quand même un un énorme
rôle infhographie qu'est-ce que c'est la
[Musique]
ménopause au fil des cycles d'une femme
le nombre d'ovocyes dans chaque
qui était d'un million à la naissance
diminue jusqu'à s'épuiser à la ménopause
les res cessent de produire les hormone
de la reproduction les ostrogènes
pourtant les pouvoirs des ostrogènes
sont nombreux sur les tissus du corps
ils régulent la pression artérielle en
améliorant la paroi des vaisseaux
sanguins ils préservent le tissu osseux
et cérébral et ils ont un effet
anti-inflammatoire et antioxydant sur le
cerveau à la ménopause les femmes
perdent donc leur protecteur hormonal et
sont plus à risque de développer des
maladies cardiovasculaires ou de
l'ostéoporose une pathologie 2 trois
fois plus fréquente chez les femmes
ménopausées que chez les hommes du même
âge en parallèle la baisse des strogènes
et d'une autre hormone la progestérone
peuvent fréquemment provoquer des
symptômes comme des troubles du sommeil
des bouffées de chaleur ou de
l'irritabilité alors que 87 % des femmes
présentent au moins un symptôme de la
ménopause plus d'un tiers considèrent le
sujet comme tabou et ne savent pas à qui
en parler il ne faut donc pas hésiter à
consulter
Laurence rign tout le monde ne vit pas
la ménopause de la même
façon voilà mais il y a des femmes pour
lesquelles ça devient un énorme handicap
presque enfin je disais c'est pas une
maladie tout à l'heure mais il y a ça a
des symptômes des effets sur le corps
des femmes qui parfois est très
important la dépression par exemple on
oublie parfois peut être causé par la
ménopause ce déficit d'information sur
la ménopause fait que les femmes
commencent à constater que leur règle
s'espace qu'elles sont de moins en moins
abondantes et puis à un moment donné
elles trouvent qu'ell grossissent qu'ell
s'empattent et puis alors certaines ont
des bouffées de chaleur d'autres non et
il y a de la il y a de la dépression qui
accompagne la ménopause et comme par
ailleurs ça se situe aussi à un moment
de vie qui indépendamment de la
ménopause peut-être un moment de
compliqué un moment où il se passe des
choses bouleversantes c'est la c'est
parfois l'âge auquel on perd ses parents
l'âge de la ménopause également et les
femmes ne savent pas attribuer à la
ménopause ce qui revient à la ménopause
et aux conditions extérieures ce qui
revient au conditions extérieur donc
elle se débrouille toute seule elle ne
savent pas quoi attribuer à quoi c'est
très difficile pour les femmes parce que
c'est souvent perçu aussi comme une
porte d'entrée dans la vieillesse
oui avec cette idée que si on peut plus
reproduire se reproduire avoir des
enfants et bien la sexualité est morte
alors je pense que c'est c'est plus
c'est plus plus ambigu que ça je pense
que pour beaucoup de femmes le fait de
ne plus être fertile est aussi un
soulagement et une liberté la vie des
femmes consiste quand même la plupart du
temps à éviter les grossesses donc plus
de règles et plus de fertilité c'est
quand même une une libération c'est un
soulagement et en même temps le le
regard social à l'égard de la ménopause
est un regard social de de de de de mise
de mise au rebut voilà une femme
ménopausée est une femme qui en fait
n'est plus n'est plus sur le marché elle
n'est plus sur le marché la vie des
femmes est terrible on passe de 35 ans
de notre vie à se traiter de et
après à partir du moment où ça s'arrête
c'est pour se faire traiter de vieille
ménopausé c'est dur la condition des
femmes c'est bien de le rappeler comme
ça et alors il y en a certaines
justement qui veulent pas réhabiliter la
ménopause mais enfin qui veulent
visibiliser donner de la visibilité à la
ménopause plus on en parle plus on
dédramatise sans doute regardez ce
reportage Alexia lperon sur ces femmes
qui veulent sortir la ménopause du
[Musique]
tabou
la ménopause ce n'est pas un tabou pour
cette influenceuse elle en a même fait
son sujet de
prédilection je parle de ménopause vu
que le sujet était pas abordé je
trouvais que assez révolutionnaire de
m'afficher comme ça et je me suis dit
mais si ça se me lancer des tomates en
disant dégage la vieille quoi pourtant
c'est un succès son compte Instagram
mopause stories compte aujourd'hui plus
de 22000 abonnés autour de texte
formation de photos Sophie vient briser
un tabou
sociétal estce que je voulais c'était
casser les barrières en fait et j'ai
toujours dit que mon vrai but c'était
décorceter la ménopause de la sortir
carrément de bah de de la prison dans
laquelle elle était enfermée en fait
cette image la prison pour moi c'est
cette image pesante de bah l'enfermement
le la la petite mort avant la vraie mort
le déjà ça y est l'enfer l'enfer des
femmes l'obsolescence programmée la date
de péremption voilà c'est on n est pas
là ce combat pour changer l'image de la
ménopause Sophie le tient de son
histoire personnelle lorsqu'elle est
ménopausée elle a d'abord du mal à
comprendre ce qui lui
arrive ça a été un bouleversement parce
que j'ai j'avais vraiment l'impression
que c'est le le corps qui dirigeait
j'avais plus prise et j'avais
l'impression de de c'est comme si je me
recrquevillais complètement donc et j'ai
compris que ça touchait aussi beaucoup
l'émotionnel parce que j'avais envie de
pleurer j'étais très fatiguée j'étais
complètement abatue donc là je me suis
dit c'est bon c'est violent
quoi face à ces symptômes elle tente
d'en savoir plus et cherche des
informations sur Internet sans
succès euh aujourd'hui quand on cherche
des des informations sur la ménopause on
tombe sur des définitions très froides
et
cliniques on don don on tombe pardon sur
des définitions des symptômes diagnostic
euh voilà des occurrences comme quelles
sont les trois phases de la ménopause
quel âge pour la ménopause quels sont
les changements du corps à la ménopause
comment donner envie de faire l'amour à
une femme ménopausée et du coup quand je
dis ça moi je me dis ben en fait la
ménopause c'est une maladie c'est une
maladie en plus qui est dégradante
puisque je reçois quand même ce genre
d'occurrence comment donner envie de
faire l'amour à une femme ménopausée
donc du coup je comprends pourquoi on en
parle pas comment peut-on aborder cette
cette étape de vie de manière fraîche et
décomplexée quand on te dit direct que
Ben globalement on a plus envie de te
faire l'amour quoi à force de creuser
Sophie est devenue une experte de la
ménopause comme elle une nouvelle
génération de femmes tente désormais de
mieux s'informer sur cette période de
vie comme ici à jein un centre
spécialisé sur la santé gynécologique
Sophie y est invité ce jour-là pour
parler ménopause à d'autres patientes
bienvenue donc bienvenue donc moi je
m'appelle Sophie cun et je suis connu
pour avoir je dirais libéré la parole
autour de la ménopause on va papoter
ménopause pendant 1 heure de ouais c'est
pas forcément évident de demander à ses
amis ce genre de question au départ
c'est pas c'est des domaines un peu de
l'intime donc c'est pas c'est pas simple
même médicalement c'est pas simple
d'obtenir une réponse
une
écoute ce sentiment est partagé par de
nombreuses patiente alors la gynécologue
du centre aborde les inquiétudes
principales et Bala les idées reçues
pour moi c'est important de mettre la
notion de symptôme qui va derrière on va
pas tout avoir un syndrome prémenstruel
marqué on va pas tout avoir des bouffés
de chaleur on va bon
sur 10 un syndrome de sécheresse
vaginale c'est peut-être celui qui est
le plus hégémonique mais on va pas
toutes avoir de symptômes et on va
surtout pas toute le vivre pareil c'est
très important de de pas de pas se dire
ah ma voisine elle le vit comme ça moi
je vais le vivre comme ça ou à l'inverse
de pas se sentir légitime dans son vécu
que ce soit un vécu positif parce que on
a le droit de se sentir libéré et
heureuse et fière d'être ménopauser de
se sentir hyper bien tout comme on a le
droit aussi de pas aller bien et et
d'aller en parler s'informer et
consulter est primordiale car ne pas en
parler c'est risqué de passer à côté de
symptômes et de problèmes de S
pour moi la méconnaissance en fait elle
induit une mauvaise prise en charge en
absence de dépistage précoce des
problématiques et également ben une
confort de vie une qualité de vie qui
diminue et ça c'est quand même important
d'adresser cette cette problématique
aujourd'hui la parole se libère de plus
en plus autour de la ménopause grâce au
travail de gynécologue et de patientes
comme
Sophie il reste encore du chemin car 38%
des femmes considèrent encore ce sujet
comme
[Musique]
tabou alors vous le disiez d'ailleurs la
gynécologue en parle d' ce sujet il y a
1 et une façon peut-être pas mais de
vivre la ménopause certaines finalement
la voit pas passer puis pour d'autres
c'est très invalidant et par ailleurs il
y a un manque d'information il y a des
femmes qui arrivent à la ménopause elles
disent mais on m'en a jamais parlé on
m'a pas prévenu ça me prend comme ça 47
48 50 ans si leur mère ou leur sœur leur
en a pas parlé pour beaucoup d'entre
elles elles ne savent quasiment rien de
la ménopause écoutez moi je suis quand
même frappé que les médecins
généralistes ne soient pas tous formés à
euh parler de la ménopause s'intéresser
voilà vous êtes médecin généraliste vous
une femme qui entre 47 et 55 ans dans
votre cabinet il est probable que la
ménopause est soit passée soit en cours
soit pas loin il faut en parler ça
devrait être une des questions
systématiques à partir d'un certain âge
une étude a été réalisée par l'institut
tard pour la MGEN et la Fondation des
femmes sur la perception de la de la
ménopause c'est une étude qui s'appelle
regard des Français sur l'avancée en âge
et la ménopause en 2023 que doit-on en
retenir écoutz clay truffo
administrarice délégé à l'engagement
sociétal de la
[Musique]
MG c'est un sujet qui reste un sujet
tabou un sujet dont on parle
difficilement un tiers des Français
disent que ils ont des difficultés à
aborder le sujet pour autant quand on
interroge les
Françaises qui sont en situation de
préménopause ou de ménopause 87 %
d'entre elles disent bien le vivre ou
très bien le vivre ce qui ce qui montre
qu'effectivement il y a il y a un gap
entre d'un côté l'image construite par
la société et puis le le le vécu des
femmes et et et le vrai sujet finalement
c'est pas tant la ménopause que le sujet
de l'avancé en âge et de la rimination
entre femm et hommes au moment de
l'avancer en âge 16 % des
femmes disent avoir déjà caché les
effets de les symptômes de leur
ménopause dans leur vie personnelle ou
leur vie professionnelle donc pour nous
en fait le sujet c'est un sujet c'est
pas uniquement un sujet de femme c'est
un sujet de société c'est pas uniquement
un sujet médical c'est un sujet de vivre
[Musique]
ensemble Laurence rol c'est intéressant
87 % des femmes qui disent bien le vivre
pensez qu'il y a une forme de de retenu
dans la réponse pour ne pas se plaindre
voilà je suis très surprise je suis très
surprise de ce résultat bien sûr elles
vivent avec euh elles ont des troubles
du sommeil mais elles vivent avec c'est
queeffectivement c'est pas le handicap
absolu c'est pas totalement invalidant
elles sont pas obligées de se mettre en
arêine de maladie pour passer la
ménopause mais elle sert les dents
absolument ménopause et travail on parle
beaucoup on en a parlé d'ailleurs dans
état de santé de du congé monstruel qui
a étéit qui a été adopté en Espagne on
en parle en France euh il faudrait un
congé monopause ou pas est-ce alors avec
mes collègues sénatrices délégation
droit des femmes on a fait l'année
dernière une enquête et un rapport
d'information sur la santé des femmes au
travail et on est arrivé bien entendu
sur les questions à la fois
d'endométriose de règles et de ménopause
et là ce qui est remonté de notre
travail c'est que c'est un moment où que
les femmes où les femmes sont euh moins
énergique moins productive c'est plus
difficile pour elle elles le font dans
une indifférence absolue d'ailleurs
d'abord parce qu'elles ne le disent pas
et puis ensuite parce que leur
environnement de travail n'est pas du
tout adapté je pense que c'est
intéressant la question que vous posez
de savoir s'il faudrait étendre le congé
menstruel à la ménopause parce que elles
ont besoin aussi de peut-être de se
reposer elles sont elles sont mal à un
moment donné au travail c'est
intéressant encore une fois par exemple
il y a des troubles du sommeil qui sont
presque commun à toutes les femmes qui
ont une monopause il y a vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup d'effets euh après de
de de de densité variable mais euh et
puis une émotivité qui est très forte
une sensibilité une émotivité les femmes
vous disent je je me suis mise à pleurer
je savais pas pourquoi euh dans le
travail quand on est trop émotif c'est
parfois difficile il y a des traitements
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a des
traitements Alexia Lesperon est allé à
l'hôpital Saint-Joseph à Paris qui
organise des ateliers ménopause pour
mieux former les femmes au traitement
qui existent ils existent et les aider
évidemment dans leurs symptômes
[Musique]
reportage depuis qu'elle est ménopausée
Nathalie souffre d'un symptôme bien
connu les bouffées de chaleur elle vient
s'informer donc sur les traitements
existants lors d'un atelier ménopause
organisé dans cet hôpital mais elle a
des réticences à prendre des médicaments
l'idée de prendre un médicament ça va
être problématique parce que pas assez
d'information sur ce
que ce qui peut ce qui peut être modifié
au niveau du corps
justement et à quoi sert ce traitement
comme elle de nombreuses femmes se
méfient des médicaments et notamment du
traitement de référence dans la prise en
charge des bouffées de chaleur le
traitement hormonal de la ménopause ou
THM
tout est partie de cette étude
américaine publiée en 2002 les
chercheurs interrompent l'étude car le
THM causera une augmentation des
maladies cardio-vasculaires et des
cancers sauf qu'en réalité ce risque
était
surévalué selon cette gynécologue on
sait désormais que l'étude était
biaisée c'est des patientes qui avait 63
ans en moyenne donc des patientes plus
âgées
que celle à qui on peut proposer
éventuellement un traitement hormonal de
la ménopause en France et c'est des
patientes qui étaient dans 60 % des cas
en surpoids donc ça aussi c'est un
facteur de risque de faire des cancers
du sein ou des risques
tromboemboliques malgré cette mauvaise
interprétation l'étude prend de
l'ampleur et conduit à une chute de la
consommation du
traitement de 50 % des femmes avant
l'étude à seulement 6
% certaines femme passerait donc à côté
d'un traitement
efficace il y a plein de femmes qui
pourrai avoir un traitement hormonale de
la ménopause effectivement si elle le
désire si nous médecins on a estimé que
il n'y avait pas de risque à ce qu'elle
le prennent si c'est nécessaire si les
symptômes sont invalidants il y a pas de
problème il y a beaucoup de femmes qui
pourraient en avoir besoin
madame bonjour rebonjour suivez-moi
alors lorsqu'elle rencontre des
patientes comme Nathalie le docteur
Chelon prend le temps d'en expliquer les
risques et les
bénéfices pas d'hypertension pas de
diabète pas de cholestérol non non voilà
si on va pas faire plus alors car il
faut quand même prendre certaines
précautions ok on peut faire ça
généralement on aime bien pas avoir trop
de distance avec le moment où il y a la
ménopause et on n'aime pas trop après 60
ans il y aurait des examens à faire
avant de discuter de l'instauration d'un
traitement si c'est vers euh euh vers ça
qu'on qu'on va une patiente qui a plus
de 60 ans une patiente qui a plus de 10
ans de l'âge de la ménopause ou euh un
terrain particulier familial
cardio-ovasculaire ou même personnel
cardiovasculaire ou des des des
habitudes de vie du tabac euh un
surpoids des choses comme ça euh bah on
a peur d'être négatif dans la balance
bénéfice risque vous est-ce que ça vous
intéresserait un traitementnal de
mentose est-ce que vous seriez pour ou
vous seriez contre peut-être déjà faire
les examens ouis et puis après en
fonction des examens pourquoi pas quoi
tester
ok grâce aux arguments de la gynécologue
Nathalie a donc changé d'avis pour faire
elle n'est plus complètement opposée au
traitement toute façon je vous retrouve
je vous retrouve à la fin de
l'après-midi bien mais le traitement
hormonal n'est pas la seule option pour
se sentir mieux s'il s'avérait qu'elle
ne pouvait pas le prendre voilà à tout à
l'heure vous all attendre la salle
d'attente cette sage femme propose une
solution plus douce
l'hypnose bonjour mesdames bonjour cette
cascade sous laquelle vous avez envie de
vous installer
pour sentir l'eau qui reelle sur votre
corps en visualisant une sensation de
rafraîchissement par l'hypnose il serait
possible de maîtriser ces bouffées de
chaleur selon cette étude américaine les
femmes expérimentant l'hypnose auraient
vu une baisse de 75 % de leur bouffée de
chaleur l'hypnose en particulier avec ce
message on va dire envoyé à
l'inconscient dans l'état de conscience
modifié que que génère l'hypnose va
permettre d'induire des
changements je vous en prie
conseil
l'hôpital Saint-Joseph est l'un des
seuls à proposer une journée entière
dédiée à la prise en charge des
symptômes de la ménopause merci beaucoup
revoir bonne
soirée mieux informer les patientes est
primordial quand on sait que cette femme
ménopausée sur 10 souffre de bouffé de
[Musique]
chaleur le rinol ça vous parle ça cette
affaire de traitement vous parce que
c'est vrai que ça a été très dommageable
pour la prise en charge des femmes ah
bah c'est sûr que la manière dont les
vieux mandarins et les vieux Barbeau de
la gynécologie médicale et de
l'obstétrique se sont reés avec une joie
sauvage sur cette étude américaine pour
en déduire queil fallait arrêter tous
ces traitements qu'ils allaient tous
donner des des des troubles
cardiovasculaires ou des cancers du du
sein aux femmes qui les prenaient va
quand même un peu attirer mon attention
c'est comme si c'était tellement bien
qu'en fait les femmes puissent pas avoir
un traitement qui va leur permettre
d'être déjà de de d'amortir les effets
de vieillissement de la ménopause parce
que c'est ça a aussi cet avantage là le
traitement ça un effet extérieur
physique et puis surtout ça permet de de
de de de nous libérer des inconvénients
de la ménopause et il a fallu beaucoup
de travail d'autres gynéco
obstétriciennes pour dire mais attention
ces études américaines elles ne elles ne
sont pas les applicables en France elles
ne sont pas exploitables en France
aujourd'hui elles sont biaisé et elles
ne sont pas pour nous et encore
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui on
rencontre de nombreuses femmes qui sont
restées sur l'idée que ces traitements
seraient dangereux potentiellement pour
elle et qu'il vaut mieux ne pas les
prendre mais surtout on a un autre
problème c'est qu'on a une
recommandation de la Haute Autorité de
santé qui je crois date de 2014 et avec
mes collègues sénatrices dans notre
rapport ce que nous demandons également
c'est que la Haute Autorité de Santé
revoit sa recommandation parce qu'elle
est est quand même très inspiré d'une
très très grande prudence à l'égarde de
ces traitements et que la Haute Autorité
de Santé réexamine cette recommandation
à l'ône de ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils écrira la même
et sinon il faut il en faut une nouvelle
l're Signol pour conclure est-ce qu'il
faudrait trouver un autre nom à la
ménopause c'est c'est tellement perçu
négativement aujourd'hui c'est tellement
stigmatisant pour les femmes on se dit
on pourrait pas l'appeler autrement je
ne sais pas quel mot on pourrait trouver
pour remplacer ménopause qui rendre la
chose joyeuse joyeuse et guirette je
pense que plutôt il faut admettre que la
ménopause est parti de vocabulaire c'est
un mot médical c'est un mot qui
scientifique il dit les choses il faut
que tout le monde l'accepte c'est pas un
Vilin mot à commencé par les hommes
commencé par les parler de la ménopause
oui si on parlait d'eux aussi de leur de
ce qu'ils ne veulent pas dire
c'està-dire que l'andropause ça existe
ah oui ça peut être aussi être un angle
sous lequel on pourrait dédramatiser on
pourrait se demander si le refus de
prendre en compte la ménopause n'est pas
une façon de mettre aussi le silence sur
leur propre androposeuse voilà la
question est posée messieur vous pouvez
répondre merci beaucoup Laurence rignol
d'avoir été avec nous pour parler de la
de la ménopause je voudrais signaler que
ma consœur claire fourournier a mis sur
les réseaux un podcast qui s'appelle
chaud devevent un podcast consacré à la
préménopause et à la ménopause
témoignage des experts aussi pour ce
programme qui est dédié à toutes les
femmes de plus de 50 ans mais les hommes
aussi regarder à très vite sur
[Musique]
LCP LCP Assemblée Nationale en
partenariat avec mgenen mutuel santé
prévoyance vous a présenter état de
santé